minister of the country you want to be
the country's representative abroad
standing with world leaders
and you really are not going to sing the
national anthem i was at the
battle of britain memorial yesterday i
was there out of respect
for that amazing moment in british
history
i was also thinking about my family my
mum and dad who were there and
at that time in london and worked um
as airaid wharton
wardens aerodwardens during the blitz
and i was thinking about that
and it was uh a respectful ceremony and
i stood in respect throughout it
but just to be clear members of your
shadow cabinet been
trying to defend it and struggling to
defend it are you saying that you
will sing the national anthem in the
future i'm going to be at many events
and i'll take part fully in those events
i don't see a problem about this the
issue
surely is that we had a memorial for the
battle of britain i was there
i showed respect for it and i'll show
respect in the proper way
at all future events that's what i'll be
doing and it's the proper way singing
the last couple ways to take a full part
in and i'll take a full part in them
prime minister's questions today what
can we expect from the first jeremy
corbyn prime minister's questions
well you'll have to wait you've got just
over an hour to go
but i want things to be rather different
because i think the public as a whole
have had enough
of yabu sucks theatrical politics
and that's what i'm going to try and
bring to pmq's today it's going to be
interesting
i don't expect it's going to be easy but
then
our job is to hold government to account
our job is to speak up for ordinary
people all over the country
and the day-to-day problems they're
facing in their lives
and that is the function of parliament
it's not a club
or should not be a club and i will try
and treat it with the respect it
deserves